hello my name's Roy Roy I'm Randi fries
so today we're gonna check out a trailer
for a horse eco absolutely anything
trailer always fought me or or a store
simon pegg by the power vested in me by
the intergalactic council I hereby
pronounce a destruction order on the
planet Earth the usual test garlic one
earth link will be picked at random the
true the good news absolute power for
good which if you lose rejection either
the earth will need even ated suppose
there was one thing you could do would
change your life for the better
oh that's easy I'll be able to see
Katherine from downstairs I can make
things happen
clothes get dressed on me all I have to
do is wave my hand
Dennis be able to speak discus what's
the street please please please
nothing else matters come to think of it
I wouldn't mind sharing your leg right
now I can solve every problem in the
world if you thought this thing sir
don't masters over he has no idea of
doing any good whatsoever let me have a
read white boys and a repeat how does
that big obviously
I've been selfish I can make people
happy everyone who died be alive again
are you crazy
maybe president of the United States
your earth briefing papers for Syria the
deficit Israel in the Middle East
not enough of us just need to tend to be
a dumb animal again oh shut up
shadow Neal give me the body of a great
man what you don't like it
I just get a little concern with Simon
Pegg stars and movies that are not of
his own writing really yeah cuz I've
seen a lot of Simon Pegg movies eating
right in there they're not the greatest
thing when they went Run Fatboy Run
there's another not always so I like
that one I like it it's just it's not
the level of quality that it could
there's one he did with Megan Fox that
no one saw and there was another one I
did with David Schwimmer that was like a
crime comedy and there's another one
where it was like real life I've seen a
lot and because I like Simon Pegg
Kennington he just said well Murray the
hitman two and didn't get greater Swan
side here yeah I mean I like Simon Pegg
this this looks like it could be fun I
like the plot kind of got a Bruce
Almighty but lower tone thing about it
you know like he's essentially got it
yeah or just gets whatever the hell he
wants
he for sure yeah no well kind of is good
except someone gave him the powers like
how God didn't Bruce the power to know
well I want to see it for just cuz I got
a large cast assembled here first off
Kate Beckinsale I like that guy son geez
Bhaskar - ah the Indian guy mm-hmm and
he's funny and Rob riggles in this and
Rob Riggle he's really funny like he's
always getting small roles in these
comedies but he's always very [ __ ]
funny really funny comedian and the
Monty Python teams in it - that's pretty
crazy they got the whole Monty Python
team in there Robin Williams Robin
Williams like I know like in his last
few years he didn't really star in
movies that were considered the best
thing in the world but Benitez voiceover
it tends to be like really
he's really rewarding voiceover actor
Eddie Izzard who I feel like should be
in more movies cuz he's so [ __ ] funny
like yeah I guess I love his stand-up
and it does sound like he's just having
a conversation with you I can see that
yeah I think he's hilarious I want to
see it mainly for the cast and I really
like Simon Pegg I always give his movies
a shot I like his movies and I style of
comedy because it's smart
he's got great delivery he's good actor
too that's that's he's one of those like
at comedic actors who's kind of
underrated for his actual acting
abilities yeah cuz he is really good cuz
he makes it real yeah that's more the
depth to his comment that's part of his
humor that works so well is the level of
sincerity authentic nough said he brings
to each character yes he knows that's
what makes the comedy really work
alright rating time I do ratings now oh
okay
I will wait to see what other people
have to say about absolutely anything
alright screen shot down so I will
probably watch it on DD good it's good
you're getting better yeah I'm all right
oh absolutely anything alright guys
thanks for saying that was out if you're
new the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out brandy
prices channel where she does a lot of
trailer reactions mainly for indie flix
but she does do some big ones if they're
highly requested and I'm gonna be guest
learning on there soon so keep a lookout
for that you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter where if we get a
surmount of followers we can get product
placement so I'm trying to get product
placement from oh yes sandals slippers
slippers slippers I'm trying to get
proper lacing from slippers these work
great for anything you know they're good
for your feet they even make for funny
hand stuff look how funny that is hand
puppets yeah and um you know if you
don't have a sock to jerk off and you
just put her right in there don't do it
hmm
slippers brought to you by the real
rejects